à chaque fois c'est la transformation
territoriale urbaine voiliers du pays et
c'est ce qu'on veut pour la france le
coup effectivement il est patent sur les
sites un an nous raconter c'est vrai
c'est 90 92 % 95 % des sites qui sont
déjà on voit à peu près non c'est le
chamboulement territoriale qu'imposent
les jeux olympiques c'est cette année
avant si vous voulez paris et l'île de
france sont dans un chamboulement urbain
absolument complet avec des gars
soixantaine de gares qui sont installés
avec une spéculation immobilière
incroyable les bouygues véolia et autres
se gavent qu'un quand vous leur parler
parce que tout d'un coup il va ya voir
voilà des champignons autour des gares
de villes qui vont ceux qui vont ceux
qui vont suivre plus le plus le
transport la métropole qu'on est en
train de construire à cause des jeux
olympiques il est une métropole c'est
vrai de grande circulation avec avec
encore une fois des points des pointes
de création de garde très très important
très lourd et donc une volonté de encore
une fois de faire circuler de et de
créer de la cré de la circulation c'est
ça qui m'inquiète
[Musique]